you mentioned before the unemployment
benefits you were actually brought in to
help California
during its covid response and you told
this very interesting story so you're
there trying to speed up the response
there's a backlog of claims and then the
public officials very proudly said look
we're hiring hundreds of new people to
process claims but because of the
esoteric nature of the way that claims
were processed a new person didn't
actually have the ability to help
process claims immediately because it's
a pretty arcane process there was a joke
saying that maybe it takes 17 years to
become somewhat expert in the process or
having a new hire may or may not do the
trick and you had a quote that I thought
was maybe the most accurate thing ever
when a system fails to deliver it's not
that the people within it are stupid or
evil it's that there are incentives in
play that are not evident from the
outside of that system and I I thought
that was the best explanation I had seen
for why so many of these things that
seem irrational from the outside are
perfectly rational to those on the
inside 100 I think I wrote the book in
part because I've been doing this work
now for 13 years and
I encounter so many folks who are upset
about government in general upset about
government Service delivery and it's
easy to ascribe sort of you know
um negative intentions or incompetence
to the people doing it and that is so
rarely what I've been found you know
what I found working inside the old
adage you know it's the system not the
people is really really really true you
you called it a joke you know that this
guy had been here 17 years and was still
new it wasn't a joke Andrew like he was
literally saying that the system that
they use to deliver benefits to the
people of California is so complicated
so abstruse so complex
that 17 years of working there he still
felt like he was learning it and he said
the folks who actually know how this
work have been here 25 years or more and
that's another reason I wrote the book
was that it's so easy to look at the
technology that government uses to
deliver these systems and say oh that's
bad they must have bad programmers they
must hire bad companies when you really
peel back the layers and look what's
going on there
it would be very hard for technology to
be delivering that well there's a lot to
say about how government builds and buys
technology that whole requirements issue
is a big part of it and there are many
others but when you look at something
like unemployment insurance there are
layers of technology that go back to the
80s
and we've had sort of a new layer of
Technology added every decade
essentially since then yeah yeah you
described as archeology I thought of it
as like rings in a tree yeah
um but it's you know these things have
just sort of been left there and then
they try to add on to it but there's not
a lot of backwards compatibility that
happens and you sort of create new
systems instead of refreshing the old
one and that is a problem I give it you
know I give you that and that's what we
as as Citizens see
but think about unemployment insurance
there are layers of accumulated policy
that in that case go back to the 1935
Social Security Act
and nobody ever looks at the backward
compatibility of the policy and process
that's accrued and you know really when
I when I saw that and I heard this guy
say you know I'm still learning after 17
years because it's so complicated I
really thought about the way that these
policies come down in sort of a memo
changing the old one and another memo
changing that one and this came from the
executive branch that came from the
judicial branch this came from the
federal DOL that came from the state
legislature it kind of Falls and just
sits there and has to be you know
learned
for so so many years that it is
impossible to deliver these services not
just because the technology hasn't been
built well but because the people who
create our laws and policies
our elected leaders always add and they
never subtract and there's very little
attempt made to go back and sort of
rationalize and simplify those 90 some
you know it's almost 90 years of policy
accumulation and craft in unemployment
insurance and that's true everywhere so
I called it recoding America you know
because it's not the code that matters
it's like the the legal code that runs
America it sits underneath that and that
we need to look at if we're going to
have the computer code work
[Music]
foreign